des gones de l'ordre de 8 à 16 go l'aude
belle ta part de n'dali top model en
garde claude godbert claude ber d'abadan
inda it up 2d
le chant que je vient d'interpréter est
un champ de travail directement
empruntées à la tradition musicale des
white sox negro spirituals et gospels
que chantait les esclaves
afro-américains dans les plantations de
tabac de coton d'indigo alors
traditionnellement le champ a toujours
rythmé accompagner la vie des gens la
vie des grandes étapes de la vie mais
aussi la vie quotidienne et pas
seulement la vie des esclaves d'afro
américains
en france également on chantait dans les
terres agricoles les ouvriers et les
ouvrières chantait dans les usines au
début du 20e siècle on chantait dans la
rue où étaient vendus des partitions
autour desquels des gens se réunissaient
sans même se connaître pour chanter mais
pour revenir à ces esclaves
afro-américains qui j'aimerais rendre un
hommage aujourd'hui on peut se demander
pourquoi leurs propriétaires qui ne leur
connaissait aucun droit des plus
élémentaires
pourquoi alors même qu'il leur déniait
le droit de parler leur propre langue de
savoir lire ou de savoir écrire pourquoi
les laisse et il chante et bien en fait
largement avant l'heure des
neurosciences les propriétaires
d'esclaves avait très justement observé
que les esclaves étaient beaucoup plus
résistant à l'extrême dureté des
conditions de vie de travail au
châtiment aux privations lorsqu'il
chantait il avait compris avant l'heure
que le chant et la musique sont
d'extraordinaires booster de santé est
aujourd'hui les travaux en neurosciences
qui s'intéressent à la musique au chant
depuis plus de dix ans démontre que le
chant et la musique sont de puissants
neurostimulateur et en même temps source
d'innovation notamment dans la médecine
puisqu'aujourd'hui on utilise le chant
auprès des malades d'alzheimer pour les
aider à retrouver un peu de mémoire de
travail et de mémoire émotionnelle
on utilise le champ encore auprès des
malades atteints d'aphasie pour les
aider à récupérer l'usagé de la parole
et ça marche chand source d'innovation
également dans l'entreprise où nous nous
attachons à le ramener aujourd'hui
source d'innovation managériale
collaborative technologique
comment ça marche bien ce que l'on sait
grâce aux connaissances sur le cerveau
aujourd'hui c'est que chanter ensemble
dès les premières minutes active la
sécrétion de l'ocytocine qui est
l'hormone de la cohésion sociale active
également la dopamine l'hormone de la
motivation de la motricité active
également des endorphines les hormones
de l'apaisement et du bien-être n'est
pas seulement le champ active aussi les
circuits de la récompense et met en
sommeil
l'amygdale cérébrale qui gère
essentiellement la peur la peur mise en
sommeil
la confiance peut s'installer le chant
et la musique créer un contexte propice
à la créativité
si je n'ai plus peur si j'ai confiance
je peux oser me lancer osé chanter mais
aussi aux et produire des idées me
lancer et puis là ce ne sont pas les
neurosciences et mon expérience ma
croyance
je pense que le gospel par l'émotion
qu'il génère ajoute un petit supplément
d'âme et d'émotion qui va peut être
encore plus stimulée l'envi et la
créativité ainsi le champ tradition
rejoint le champ innovation
et si le champ a toujours rythmé la vie
spirituelle sociale laborieuse il
pourrait tout aussi bien aujourd'hui
peut-être rythme et le moment que nous
sommes en train de partager
je vais vous inviter à vous levez vous
avez ici les paroles d'un chant très
simple qui dit victory and mind vectory
two days mind à figure d'événement a
road victory jazzman la victoire est à
moi c'est un champ un traditionnel du
gospel victoire on y met le sens que
l'on veut victoire sur soi-même victoire
sur les événements sur ce que l'on veut
on va essayer de le partager ensemble
tout simplement
c'est très très simple vous allez voir
deux premières phrases sont les mêmes si
vous voulez on va essayer de le dire
d'abord avec des mots sans le chanter
vectorwise maille
deuxième phrase victor is my very few
days mind and feel good de mayotte
victory today is my year alors on chante
on s'adonne 3,4 victory is my super la
troisième victoire des semailles y est
on va prendre les trois victimes
vêtus des maillots on va le faire tous
ensemble à nouveau 3 4 et victor hedman
victory et semailles vertu des semailles
hockey ifeelgoods des pilotes des
victimes tous des semailles
deuxième fly d' c'est la même chose mais
avec joy
c'est la même mélodie joe hickman c'est
john wayne john wood et emma
des images ou des églises maintenant
vous savez sanyal troisième slate super
simple c'est l'homme alors la même chose
un deux trois quatre lots is my love is
my love to thé et moi
à vélo du maroc
victory tout et il m'a alors du coup mal
enchaîné les trois avec victory avec des
oreilles avec l'homme c'est bon mais oui
c'est bon si vous êtes super 1 2 3 tab
victory in mind vf ma vitesse ma
à témara sécurité et les semailles
merci beaucoup
mais si vous êtes super clairement